اكد المبعوث الامريكي الخاص ليبيا ريتشارد
دا نورلاند على اهميه تواصل الليبيين
لتوافق على قاعده دستوريه لاجراء انتخابات
يحترم نتائجها الفائزون والخاسرون وبشان
موقف واشنطن من ترشح العسكريين للانتخابات
قال نورلان في مقابله مع الجزيره مباشر
بان مسؤوليه وضع المعايير الخاصه
بالمرشحين هي خاصه بالليبيين وحدهم
المعايير المتعلقه بالمرشحين هي من ابرز
البنود التي نوقشت وبحثت لكن في نهايه
المطاف الشعب الليبي وحده هو من يقرروا من
ينبغي له ان يترشح ومن ينبغي له الفوز
بالانتخابات وحكم البلاد هذا ليس دور
الولايات المتحده وليس قرارها
كما تهم نورلاند مجموعه فاغنر بي زعزعه
الاستقرار في ليبيا مضيفا بان الليبيين
يرغبون في خروجهم من البلاد
مساله وجودي مقاتلين اجانب ومرتزقه من
القضايا التي نوقشت في اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق
النار والتي نصت على مغادره تلك القوات
الاجنبيه واعتقد ان الليبيين متلهفون
ومتطلعون الى تطبيق هذا البند في اسرع وقت
ممكن من وجهه نظرنا فان مجموعه تسببت في
زعزعه استقرار ليبيا والمنطقه بشكل عام
واحسست من خلال تواصلي وحديثي مع كثير من
الليبيين بانهم يرغبون في مغادرتها
لبلادهم